rand good evening to you i'm brian
loftis brian and i'm denise valdez this
was really
unprecedented for the fbi to hold a
press conference to talk about an
election like this and certainly also at
this hour
now authorities are telling us really
there is no need for you to worry
that our election system is secure
however they did get a hold of a number
of people's voter registrations and
emails so they started to send them out
so if you do receive an email
that looks suspicious don't panic but do
not respond so the cbs evening news has
a couple of reporters on this story and
they'll have a full report for you
coming up here in about a half hour
meantime another developing situation
this time coming out of the northeast
part of the valley where police say a
hostage situation
is underway now this is happening not
too far from nellis air force base near
east craig and las vegas boulevard
joe moeller is live there on the scene
since our four o'clock broadcast and
joins us now with an update
joe yeah we just got an update about a
half an hour ago negotiators are still
trying to get that man the woman and
that infant out of this apartment
like you mentioned we're at craig road
in las vegas boulevard there's the eagle
trace apartment complex you're taking a
look at there you can see that metro
unit there
the call came in at around 1 30 this
afternoon from someone reporting to see
a man pointing a gun at a woman and an
infant and then they went into an
apartment
and that's when the hostage situation
started now metro says
they believe it is a boyfriend and
girlfriend in this they don't know the
relationship
with the infant to the man we are still
waiting to get some more information
about that
at this time metro says there is no
known injuries of
anybody inside of that apartment
negotiators still inside of there right
now you're taking a look down craig road
which is still
closed at this hour and it has been for
several hours so a lot of people getting
off work right now making u-turns
at a number of locations here so keep
that in mind if you are heading out a
lot of people
who live in this apartment complex are
still trying to get in many people
have to go on to the las vegas boulevard
entrance over there but negotiators at
this hour still in there
trying to get that man the woman and
that infant outside again no injuries
known at this time once we do get an
update
we'll be sure to pass it along reporting
live in the northeast alley jill moore 8
news now